featured in a netflix series that's  called warn stories  the family owned dry cleaners celebrated  50 years in las vegas just last year  now as for the netflix series the las  vegas episode premiered this month  now the point of the series though is to  explore the connection between  clothes and memories we see clothes come  in  time after time we see one-of-a-kind  pieces that come in  so the sentimental value the value  all that we live every day  the las vegas episode though almost did  not happen because dan dismissed the  idea three times every time netflix  called he's like not interested  wasn't until his wife answered that the  series finally got the green light and  here we are  again you can watch it on netflix it's  called warn stories  he may be the first person in history to  get a call from netflix and god now i'm  good  people are usually calling netflix  correct coming up on the valleys news  leader 50 million america